ah
now
and have hot water and cold water
at the same time as you want is perfect
or the people that when I go we're
always very happy because they do the
shower
the environment system the materials
that we use are typical materials that in
the neighborhood is discarded or burned
because they have no final disposal of the
trash then the letters we show you
to families that with materials that
before they burned they can have an access a
basic service that they did not have to play
the truth that I changed 100% so
least I will have
let's say hot water for my children not
I have words to describe what
they are doing for me the truth that no
I can not believe the water issue yet
hot
The goal of the project is to be able to reach
thousands of families not only in Argentina
but in Latin America think that one day
of rain and 35 people who
voluntarily they come to learn about
sustainability to work with
family with the neighbors of the neighborhood and
especially the most important thing to see the
the youngest of the neighborhood working the
true that really without alcohol